since its founding in 1998 Rotten
Tomatoes has become the go-to site for
getting a quick idea of what film
critics think of a movie your individual
tastes might vary and we all love to
watch some trashy cinema every now and
then but you can generally count on a
film with a high score to bring some
quality to the table if you really want
the cream of the crop though you can
look for the films that racked up a
unanimous critical endorsement and
scored the coveted 100 percent but
there's a catch the scores and the
professional reviews that generated them
stay up on Rotten Tomatoes forever and
almost all of them were written when the
films were first released while many
great movies can stand the test of time
the years that pass can eventually
reveal some flaws here are a few movies
that have an aged well despite their 100
percent scores from critics the
interview if you're surprised at the
interview got a 100 percent score you're
probably thinking of the 2014 movie
about James Franco and Seth Rogen being
sent to assassinate the leader of North
Korea take him out
he wants to kill the leader of North
Korea yes that movie is also aged badly
but it wasn't exactly beloved to begin
with this interview is a 1998 Australian
crime drama starring Hugo Weaving that
made a big splash in indie film circles
when it was released in the United
States in 2000 the question is why the
film consists almost entirely of an
interrogation of weavings character at
the hands of a police detective it's
like an Australian usual suspects but
with worse writing and no budget for
flashbacks whether he's guilty or simply
being railroaded is kept from the
audience to a degree that makes it hard
to find any truth in the story to latch
on to if you want proof that Hugo
Weaving is a very good actor the
interview will accomplish that but you
can find that same proof in a much more
entertaining form elsewhere Roger and me
in 1989 Roger and me seemed charming the
work of a then-unknown documentary
filmmaker named Michael Moore it
featured the story of his troubled
hometown of Flint Michigan and Moore's
quest to confront General Motors CEO
Roger B Smith the film goes into detail
about the harm the company did to Flint
by laying off huge numbers of workers in
favor of cheaper labor in other
countries and Moore's dogged pursuit is
engaging even though he never manages to
meet with
when it was released this movie was
nothing like the impersonal
documentaries that audiences were used
to three decades later though it's a lot
harder to enjoy Flint never recovered
and is still a city in crisis today
Michael Moore meanwhile is still doing
his best to present the same dog at
everyman persona that won over audiences
in this film but it feels far less
sincere coming from an industry veteran
than it did from an unknown in his 30s
in 1989 Michael Moore became a liberal
hero but these days audiences think he's
overstayed his welcome regardless of
their politics if box-office receipts
are any indication in that sense you
could say that Moore's own success has
ruined his best film longtime companion
longtime companion was a movie that
needed to be made it's 1990 release was
groundbreaking presenting audiences with
the first widely distributed motion
picture dealing with the AIDS crisis
that have been decimating the gay
community for a decade unfortunately for
modern viewers the sadness of its story
is far from the only thing that makes it
hard to watch Craig Lucas and Norman
Rene the writer and director of the
movie were both gay men who lived in the
world they were depicting but some LGBTQ
activists felt like they were playing it
safe and their depiction of the gay
community these critics called out the
movie for being afraid to depict gay men
as anything other than affluent and
white and to depict their relationships
as truly romantic and sexual it's clear
that a major goal of the film was to
tell a story that needed to be told to
the people who hadn't heard or lived it
in that sense longtime companion was a
huge success in its time but nobody
watches it anymore
and there's a reason for that the
Terminator oh Terminator you're one of
our favorite movies ever but that
doesn't mean you've properly stood the
test of time despite how cool your
special effects were for 1984 we're only
a decade away from Kyle Reese's cyborg
filled future and we still have very
little of the technology that we saw
unfortunately all the hairspray neon
colored clothes and Sarah Connors
roommates music throughout terminator
often leaves us cringing as to what
things were like in the 80s the
Terminator is justifiably looked back on
as a sci-fi action classic but from a
modern perspective it has a few big
things working against it for starters
it's a
of its own success it's so influential
on everything that came after that we've
seen the innovations and ideas that it
brought to the screen refined dozens of
times over the years even Arnold
Schwarzenegger is iconic emotionless
unstoppable killing machine which blew
audiences away in 1984 that made Arnold
a household name seems a little less
special after 30 years
a handful of sequels and a couple
hundred imitators I'll be back not gonna
say that video is what you always say I
do in that respect it's a lot like
watching the fight scenes in the matrix
and trying to remember how innovative
they were before that style was in
literally every action secondly there's
Sarah Connor the target that the
Terminator is sent back in time to
execute by Terminator 2 Judgment Day
we've seen Linda Hamilton evolved into a
muscular battle ready action hero in her
own right which is the main thing that
makes revisiting the first movie feel so
off here she's a nearly helpless
big-haired damsel in distress who has to
be rescued and the fact that she's being
targeted solely because she's eventually
going to be someone's mom isn't the most
empowering storyline for a female
science fiction League they changed a
fight
one woman who could save their future
none of this ruins what is definitely
still a great movie but for a film about
the future it definitely feels dated The
Searchers John Ford's 1956 Western The
Searchers is one of the most beautiful
films ever made and features what is
easily the best performance by screen
legend John Wayne Wayne stars as Ethan
Edwards a civil war veteran who spends
years looking for his niece after she's
kidnapped by Native Americans leading
him to hate all Comanches that hate is
treated as a flaw in his character and
that's a far more nuanced and
progressive perspective than was common
in westerns of that era unfortunately
that nuance just makes these still
ingrained racism throughout the movie
all the more glaring there's a whole
subplot with a Native American woman who
believes herself to be married to a
white man who has no interest in her
played entirely for Laughs beyond that
Ethan's blatant racism particularly when
he expresses a willingness to kill his
own niece if she slept with or even been
assaulted by a Native American makes him
seem less like a deeply flawed antihero
and more like a monster The Searchers is
absolutely worth watching for its
cinematography and performances but
there's a lot you'll have to ignore to
enjoy it Holiday Inn racism has to be
pretty egregious to stand out in a movie
from 1942 but Holiday Inn manages to
pull it off in a single scene if you've
ever seen it or even just watched the
trailer you already know exactly what
we're talking about the premise of the
Bing Crosby Fred Astaire musical
revolves around a resort that's only
open on holidays with each holiday
having its own song and dance number
it famously gave the world white
Christmas which would go on to become
Crosby's signature song and the
best-selling single of all time but not
every holiday was so lucky Abraham
Lincoln's birthday is celebrated with a
number in which the white performers are
dressed as black stereotypes complete
with the exaggerated blackface makeup
that was common in racist 19th century
minstrel shows the entire sequence has
been cut from TV airings of the film but
today most people watch it on DVD or
streaming where it's still there
there's a lot to like in Holiday Inn and
a lot of great music and dancing but
this shocking relic that was passed it's
time even in the 40
is enough to ruin the whole thing thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]